what kind of a prison were you in was it
like it was like a federal maximum
security it was maximum security uh
and then uh as time went on i wound up
in a
medium okay immediately very very still
pretty violent yeah right yeah yeah but
yeah they are but you could avoid that
it's not like you know again like you
see tv
there are prisons like that where
there's just gangs and they're always
you know that's their life yeah you know
but most federal prisons
are not that way if you don't if you're
not into
the state penitentiaries gay stuff you
you'll avoid the fights they'll actually
fight over a guy
uh uh if you if you don't gamble which i
did every single day but i made sure
everybody had
put the cash up you know uh
stamps was cash in prison yeah you want
a better football game
cash has to be put up that was my main
business uh
bookmaking and i booked every day that i
was away
i supported myself really yeah yeah i'll
tell you this is a funny story i've said
it a thousand times
you're allowed three books of stamps
everybody's equal
you can't have more than three books of
stamps because you can use that for
currency in there
stamps in what time period like at any
one time like if they come and shake my
room down my cell can only have three in
possession right if they see ten books
they're gonna write me up
okay maybe i go to the hole maybe i get
extra duty or whatever
when i got released i had two thousand
books
oh my god what and i left i left them in
there with different guys i gave one guy
500 one guy
you know so i made their time because
you use them for i pay a guy
booker stamps to clean my room once a
week pay another guy a book of stamps to
bring me good food out of the like
broccoli and hard-boiled eggs
i don't want to eat the garbage so you
know it's you can
live a little better right if you you
know if you want to if you if you got
that in mind that's
was always my money i said i'm i'm going
to put these 10 years back on at the end
were you still in contact with any of
these mob guys when you were
inside um no it's because everything's
monitored
the phone calls you know you can't
really call
right but didn't you say some of the guy
like uh one of the original bosses was
still the boss after he
got locked up yes like how do you do
that he would do on visits he would have
uh
you know chucky was uh a captain that
was his nephew
that would go visit him uh his son would
go visit so he would bring
and they put him only in california
lampard
and uh he still would get messages
and that was also a problem during the
war because his brother teddy
was not very smart he was a
respectful he was a simple-minded guy
okay
uh he wasn't true he wasn't street smart
but he was going because he's a brother
he can go
deliver messages and he wasn't bringing
the right messages back
ultimately we found out he was
soft-coated because
vic made him a captain so he sort of
liked vic
and and i remember junior saying how do
you make him a captain
his own brother how do you make you know
but he did it
with the machiavelli tactic you know by
bringing one of the brothers as a
captain you know he's showing
uh good faith right you know right right
right
but he was bringing like like greg uh
would
say you bring this message to junior
tell him that
we are not going to stop shooting until
they the first word out of them out that
the meeting has to be
you are recognized as the boss teddy
would come back and say no he wants you
to keep talking he wants peace
he wants peace he wants to keep talking
it out
and greg told me there's no way junior
said that there's no [ __ ] way
junior say he's his message would be
take that [ __ ] out right
one person he had an answer to in the
whole wide world vicarina
and he wasn't happy that's that's the
greed that's that that ego
yeah i want i want this position
officially you did have it you were
official acting boss
so all you had to do was run the ship
and split it with junior
you know i think he was worried he was
going to be knocked down when uh
carmine's son junior purchased son came
home
and i don't think that was going to
happen i don't think that was the case
my personal and i had conversations with
ali about it i remember saying if he
would have behaved he could have kept
the position
he said i come out i take that position
i'm back in i'm back in the can
in six months you know so not
immediately anyway maybe ultimately he
would have wanted the position
but he was a cousin he was junior's
cousin
so he should have been more loyal but
greg said he was he wasn't a
powerful tough guy he was very big
earner big
money and
junior thought he could
control him and never lose the power
but the problem was other people
controlled him too right
greg it said if he put a guy like
himself if he would put a guy like me
not me be great telling me this or
uh joe t named four or five guys
they would never try to take the family
from junior
you know and they anybody comes to tell
them to do it they're going to tell them
talk like that once more you're dead
right you know you're done right
i don't want to hear that you know vic
didn't do it he listened and then john
gotti was
integral major problem for us because
he wanted vic to win the reason is
vix on the boss joe scopo grew up with
johnny
john gotti and
john all the egos put together his
was still bigger he wanted to be the
boss of all bosses
there there isn't any more that you know
there's equals at the commission
they're all equal but he wanted to have
the strongest vote on the commission so
if vic wins the war this came out later
it's a fact
they were going to kill vic themselves
and let joe scopo become the boss so him
and john
would have two votes on the commission
and how much time did you actually end
up doing in prison ten years i gotta
take you a sense
what was your whole trial what was your
whole thing well uh
i didn't go to trial i was offered the
deal uh
to to tell them what i knew basically
about the corruption okay
i walked out three times
because they wouldn't let my partner
jimmy come in under the same
umbrella as me they wanted to catch him
you know make pub
he was on the limb jimmy was on the limb
i was in fl i got arrested in florida in
cocoa beach as a matter of fact
oh really i came down for a vacation
after the war i figured let me just get
out of here i don't want
this way they don't see me around and
jimmy and i had plans
he was going to come down and meet me
and we were going to drive off and go
somewhere
okay you know we set up our pipelines
and just to stay
stay out of their faces time would have
helped time would have helped because
our boss always i confused with our boss
all the time this joe t was our acting
boss on our side
for the persicos and he went on the lamb
they caught him i think five six years
later
okay and they made a deal with him like
that for five years
and he's the boss okay because
as new prosecutors they have their own
cases they don't want this one thrown up
now so they just
so if we would have went on the land we
would have probably got that same
five-year seven-year deal
you know uh but ultimately they says
okay because they couldn't find them
they came back and they says all right
we'll keep the door open for jimmy
but uh and i couldn't admit knowing
where he was
so i says i'll see if i can get a
message to him and
you know i'll try to grapevine my family
if somebody can you know i have no idea
where he is you know right
i really didn't uh but i knew how to
contact him we had that you know
uh so he uh he was able to come in
and you know i i had to cop out to zero
to life
so if i would have lied or i would have
gotten uh if they would have found out
that
i didn't come clean on things that i did
uh i could have been charged or i could
have got life
ultimately he gave me 10 years the judge
uh
and you know the guys that like carmine
got three years sammy got five years so
the guys that really give them a lot
will get in the door immediately you
know but they didn't really like me
because it was
the corruption it wasn't uh
you know not that they didn't like me
personally but
the case that i brought them was
basically their own
i